[Music]
matt is with us matt's in new york city
hi matt how are you
hey mr ramsay dr john how you guys doing
today great man
how can we help so um my wife is in her
final year of medical school
um and she has 391 000
in student loan debt and it's going to
go up with her last semester here
my question is uh what can i do and then
what can we do together to
you know help tackle that debt when we
have to pay it off which won't be for
another year
well i'm i'm hoping that she is um
studying a field of medicine that's
going to pay very well what's the plan
well she's going into pediatrics which
isn't the top of the list
but she'll know i mean what's she gonna
make a hundred and a quarter hundred and
a
half
yeah depending where she is and y'all
gonna stay in new york city
um no definitely not whereabouts you
think you'll be living
um she her dream would be in grand
rapids michigan
um that would be a good one yeah it's a
completely different world than where
you're living today
uh except for the fact that it is shut
down like new york but um because it is
in michigan
um but the um
well i mean she steps into a practice
and is making a hundred quarter hundred
and a half she picks up
er stuff on the weekends anything she
can do to add to the income you do the
same what's your career looking like
what's your income going to be
well um so i'm a pro basketball player
but the market um
in europe but um the market has been
horrible this year because of the virus
obviously so teams don't have a lot of
money
i'm making right now a thousand a month
plus uh incentives but um it's all
i don't have to pay for anything so
housing free food is free so it's all a
thousand take home
so you're playing at what level like
nba no no no um i'm in
ireland currently okay okay i had a
young man that worked here that went and
did that yeah okay so you're
you're back and forth a lot and you can
be back and forth from there
if that if that materializes and becomes
what it should be
you should be making a hundred and a
half as well shouldn't you
yeah that's the goal that that would be
around the normal i think if
if i remember from the young man that
worked here so okay cool
and so if we get to 300 between the two
of us we're going to live like we make
50
and we're gonna pay this off in two or
three years right that's
that's the most that's how you do it i
mean it's just outgo versus income
the problem is you're in two fields
that do not have a peer set
that are going to like you living on
nothing both of you people you're
hanging out with broke doctors who are
putting on the dog
and they don't even have a house to put
the dog in and
and you're hanging out with broke pro
athletes who are acting like they're
making six times what they're making
uh we work with both of them all the
time they're they're perpetually stupid
with money in those fields
and so you're gonna have to just walk
away from your peers in terms of the
pressure on how money is handled and
your goals
and have a very um
a very different mindset and just say
we're gonna live like broke college
students on 40 or 50 grand in grand
rapids you can do that
uh and we're pouring everything else on
this colossal debt
otherwise you wake up ten you're still
going to be around your neck now john
you've been around higher ed you've got
a phd in higher ed
what's your take on this yeah you the
most common thing i hear
is i deserve this i'm a doctor i deserve
this and so
you're gonna have to yeah you've you've
dug yourself a mighty big hole
you're gonna have to never say the words
we deserve you're gonna have to get a
one-bedroom apartment and share a honda
accord and you're gonna have to just
figure it out and i think you can do it
in a couple of years but you're gonna
have to work real hard real fast
that's good because that's a jesus car
that's exactly that's all
the disciples were in one accord this is
the dave ramsey show